pour moi être français c'est aimer les
débats toujours tout est prétexte à
débat il fait beau ouais mais il fait
moins bon qu'hier nonobstant hier il
faisait moins beau alors qu'en suisse
dont on n'aime pas trop les débats on
préfère que l'autre ait raison parce
qu'il faut pas de conflit français ce
béton fixe une règle il faut trouver le
moyen de la contourner
georget dû annuler un week-end dans le
sud à cause du coc vide mon collègue
francine dit mais t'as pas besoin de
l'annuler tu prends un billet marseille
bourg-en-bresse qu'une bourde en bresse
lausanne qui personne ne fera que tu
étais dans le sud oui de gens triment je
parle taper les skate comme la sncf pour
méditer dix jours de quarantaine pour
moi les français c'est des gens dont je
connais la culture le sport la politique
la géographie
donc c'est un tout petit peu vexant
parce qu'on retour souvent j'entends des
bas alors le petit suisse on a un yaourt
t'en a pas marre de planquer l'argent de
nos riches
donc ouais on a l'impression que la
france s'intéresse pas tellement reste
de la francophonie un peu autocentré est
d'ailleurs la preuve c'est quand un
média français de moins de la vie des
suisses et la vie des suisses sur les
français en suisse on dit les français
sont grandes gueules pour moi les
français sont charismatiques
en suisse on dit que les français sont
chauvins pour moi les français sont
fiers
en suisse on dit que les français sont
mal organisées pour moi les français
sont bons vivants
pour moi être français c'est rajouter
des à la fin des phrases non mais
en fait non mais en revanche pour moi
être français c'est parler très très mal
anglais it is very hard to the french
people out there to speak english
properly voilà c'était vachement
compliqué pour j'ai l'impression tandis
que forrest it's very easy
les français déjà de mauvaise foi ouais
énormément de mauvaise foi j'ai jamais
vu ça
c'est incroyable ils vont jamais
admettre qu'ils ont tort
le français n'est pas très enthousiaste
un compte quelque chose est extrêmement
beau ou extrêmement bon il va dire ouais
franchement c'était pas dégueulasse
ouais je me souviens qu une des choses
qui m'a marqué quand je suis arrivé en
france c'est que le français aime bien
rajouté ton prénom à la fin de chaque
phrase
donc soit pour te montrer qui se
souvient de ton prénom ski en effet
revoir la discussion plus personnelle ou
soit au cas où toi même tu avais oublié
ton prénom peut arriver effectivement
donc ça donne bonjour ni le temps dira
comment vas tu évites à rien que fais-tu
victoria ou mais tu as regardé le match
de foot
victoria poursuit vraiment c'est une
chance de gagner ce match et carrière
[Musique]
c'est bon le loup d'après ton forfait
l'an soit à leur restaurant d'altitude